[Music]
Hello friends you are about to see a
video of a man named Carl Sandberg born
in 1878 and he has quite a fascinating
story to tell you about witnessing a
political rally in October of 1884. this
was a few weeks before the election that
made Grover Cleveland the 22nd president
of the United States now some of you may
have heard of Carl Sandberg before he
was a well-known poet and biographer in
the first half of the 20th century and
he lived in a small town called
Galesburg Illinois which is where the
political rally that he speaks of took
place at that time in the 1880s Illinois
was predominantly Republican and so
you'll hear Mr Sandberg describe how the
crowd at the rally was mostly chanting
for a man named James G Blaine the
Republican nominee for the presidency at
the time the 1884 presidential election
was highly contentious and marked by
strong hostility toward both candidates
Cleveland faced accusations of fathering
an illegitimate child while James G
Blaine received backlash over the
Mulligan letters documents indicating
that he had accepted a bribe from the
Union Pacific Railroad despite these
controversies Cleland would Ascend to
the presidency thanks to a narrow win in
his home state of New York by just 1149
votes and here is a map of the final
election results for that year where
President Cleveland proved victorious in
all the South and most of the East
whereas Mr Blaine was heavily favored in
the west and Midwest and so now let us
walk through the doors of time and
listen to Mr sandberg's amazing
recollection of that night back in
October of 1884.
what was it like growing up in Central
Illinois before there were any
automobiles
well one thing the main thing so first
of all is horses horses everywhere
horses
and a man can think of how
politics then was about the same as now
just as much Shenanigans as ever
I was six years old in October of 1884
when my father took me downtown to see a
republican Torchlight procession this is
in Galesburg yes
hundreds of Republicans each one with a
lighter torch on his shoulder
and a flambo core
pipes long pipes that blow and there
would be three four feet of fire up
there a kind of a big fire flower all at
once 16 of them shooting up in the air
it was a Wonder to my boy eyes
day and day
they would march sometimes blame blame
James G plain
my father had told me that was
the candidate of the Republican Party
but uh while they were marching every
once in a while they would come from a
sidewalk eight
hurray for Cleveland
and then from the procession there would
come
and a rope to hang on
and you know
uh I was a nice little six-year-old
Republican I had never seen a hanging I
didn't know what hanging was like but uh
if the Republicans were for it I was
like my father I was a Republican and I
was for the hanging of Grover Cleveland
but a few weeks pass
into the country elected Grover
Cleveland instead of hanging him they
elected him president of the United
States
and he appoints for a postmaster in
Galesburg a neighbor of ours only two
weeks only two blocks away yeah an
Irishman named Billy tuik politics was
as full of changes and surprises then as
it is now
thank you
[Music]